It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we will host a FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians, good morning!
Thank you for joining us today for our 150 second episode!
Are you awake?
You're awake.
It keeps on getting a bigger number and every time I have to think, how do I say this again?
It's just gonna keep on getting harder from here on out.
You're awake cause of the glasses.
BAU BAU!
Good morning!
You know, happy Friday, right before a very fun weekend.
But Ruffians, you know, maybe it's a little bit hard getting out of bed, so we're here to help you with that!
But for Ruffians who are joining us for the first time today,
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Now, you know the drill, right?
Please tweet and dodge the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's go BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
I've seen Ruffians hashtag #on Twitter.
I saw that too.
I was a bit confused.
Why?
Like, oh, did you make a mistake?
She doesn't really like it that much.
That's okay though, because I do.
I don't like it!
I like it so much!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Abyss!
Game for short for morning shows!
Yes!
Short for my Moco-chan!
Very, very short.
That means under half an hour.
Not an hour.
Very short.
Yes, very short.
Let's get things moving, Moco-chan!
Okay, okay!
Exciting news!
Yeah!
Exciting.
You know.
No, no.
Nasty.
No, I need exciting news.
Go-chan, why are you making that sound, huh?
Go-chan.
Wow.
Another Pero sighting!
It's good to know where Pero is, so that, you know, we can be careful.
It happened again, Ruffians.
Yeah.
Well, let's take a look at the Pero machine this time.
Let's take a look.
This is where Pero has been, huh?
He's been sitting on this poor Ruffian's porch in a box at your front door.
I don't know, that's a little pitiful, right Moco-chan?
Besides too, look!
Look, he probably used those wings as much as he could to write those letters!
Really desperate, huh?
Leave the Ruffian alone, ya!
I don't know.
What should we do?
Adopt!
You want him?
Wow, that's kind of embarrassing.
That's some strong wording.
He's holding a knife!
It's good to always think those things, you know?
I don't see anything, but don't know what's underneath.
He can't even write E properly!
Yeah... But that also looks sort of funny, huh?
I don't know, Moco-chan.
I feel like maybe in this situation, you let him in.
Give him a pass away!
Right!
I mean, it's a requirement of finding anything lonely in a cardboard box, right?
You give it a bath?
Right!
Huh?
No.
Give a bath for him?
Return the sander.
Put the sunglasses on.
Close up the sides.
All the tape, packing tape.
Might as well give him a home.
Even wash him?
I'm not gonna wash him, but maybe Ruffians.
You could and then you know.
Not bad.
Wet demon dog smell.
Go away?
Maybe.
Yeah.
You're the dog Pero?
Okay.
Go play.
But be careful, okay?
BAU BAU!
But forget that though!
Today is a special day!
Because today is hololive English -Advent-'s 1,000th Shiori Nobel's birthday!
Happy birthday Shiori!
I didn't forget, right?
Very happy birthday Shiori!
I can't believe it's Shiori's second birthday already.
I can't believe it.
But a big, big happy birthday to our lovely Chame!
And this year, this year, Shiori, she's celebrating it with a tea party!
Yeah!
Maybe!
It's a little mystery, huh?
Yeah, but you know, she's gonna be celebrating it starting at 7pm PT today!
And you're invited, Ruffians!
Is that a team song?
Chainsaw?
I don't know what you're talking about.
What do you mean a chainsaw?
It's a tea party.
You bring a chainsaw to a tea party?
Why?
To cut the cake?
Maybe.
Well, you know what?
You'll find out if you join her.
And you know what?
Use the hashtag #Partyvella2025!
Yes!
Ruffians, you're good at the hashtag, right?
Right!
But you know what, Shiori looks like she's gonna have a bunch of fun there.
I never really know what's gonna happen.
Especially the party with Shiori.
You know, it'll definitely be wild for sure, you know.
Yeah, mini cheese sofa cake cutting.
Well, it's up to Shiori, right?
Yeah, it is her party, you know.
I gave Shiori a present.
Not yet.
Wait, how do I give a Shiori a gift?
That doesn't count.
No.
I'm not saying that counts.
But please, please go and say happy birthday to Shiori okay?
BAU BAU!
Happy birthday Shiori!
Exciting time.
I know, so many things going on.
But one thing we're especially surprised and excited for is...
Ayame-senpai!
I'm not kidding!
Ayame-sen
Ruffians you have to know about it too!
It's still coming up just a bit.
May 4th at 4am PT.
So you know, maybe I'll just wake up one morning and Ayame-senpai will look extra extra cute.
We'll have to see what we're looking forward to!
BAU BAU!
Can Ayame-senpai get any cuter?
Uh-oh.
FUWAMOCO!
We opened its doors!
It seems to have a few troubles of its own!
Ah, you know, Cafe FUWAMOCO's bad.
Yes!
You know, last time, there was a few customers that came to be able to, you know, take up the brand new cafe with the newbie maids.
The fluffy, the one inside is a fluffy, fluffy moch.
A strange cafe, no?
Yeah, the one inside is a fuzzy, Mococo.
Very normal.
Yeah.
But, well,
You know, apparently things didn't go so smoothly the very first time.
It took a little while to come back for another day to open the shop up.
I mean the first day of business they forgot to bill everyone.
And now, it seems like it's hard to build people as well, huh?
Yeah, I know.
And despite it being a holiday vacation, and having the sign turned on, it looks like the cafe might go bankrupt.
Yeah.
But there's two very, very wonderful Masters that came.
Mio-goshujin-sama and Watame-goshujin-sama.
But there's also an order, an order from BAU Eats too.
But...
I love the time the two maids were seen twiddling their thumbs and sitting down waiting in the cafe.
They know all the new improvements.
Maybe didn't make much of a difference in the survival of the cafe, huh?
We don't believe in the cafe.
You believe that the cafe will survive.
We'll have to see.
No, it's not so easy to run a cafe like cafe FUWAMOCO, maybe.
But one thing's for sure.
It's very cute and a little different.
Maybe they need to change, huh?
Maybe it's not with the times.
Maybe this cafe is just not fit.
BAU BAU!
Please check out my FUWAMOCO!
Ruffians, we announced something that we are super happy to share with you!
Finally!
A few months ago back in October last year, we hit a big big milestone of 1 million subscribers on YouTube!
And so we wanted to celebrate it together with you.
And to commemorate it, we released FUWAMOCO, our 1 million subscriber celebration merch!
You know, this merch is very very special because it's something that, you know, FUWAMOCO, we thought of.
We wanted to celebrate it together with you this way.
We organized it all we saw.
A lot came from our ideas, you know.
Like, I want it like this, and I'll have this.
This would be good to go around thinking, ah, what about this?
Why don't we do this?
What do the Ruffians do?
You know, go to the store, take photos and stuff.
We put a lot of love and consideration into it.
It's not like other merch, you know.
You know, this is from us, Chikyuu Ruffians!
We're really happy to share it.
There's a bunch of really cool things in it.
Can you take a look?
We have a super cute illustration here from Icomochi-mama!
I think it looks really cute, but...
And you can also get a very special milestone voice too!
You can only hear it there, but!
In the set here, we have a very cute Dreams Come True acrylic diorama stand of both of us!
Basically, the first diorama acrylic stand of the two of us!
And not just us, you too, Ruffians!
Pero too!
It's very cute!
Whole family, yeah!
Everybody's there.
And next we have a very, very special item.
We have a pledge of loyalty.
In certificate form here for you to open.
Yes, you haven't forgotten, right?
Our pledge from us to yours.
Right!
The same one that we made on the Daily Daily.
But now you can have it in your own paws to display.
Throw them before me every day.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
But, the thing is with these button badges, you can put them on.
Together with FUWAMOCO Oshi-Bag!
Our very first Oshi-Bag!
We worked really hard on it!
See, there's a lot of different Oshi-Bags out there.
This is the first FUWAMOCO one, and this one we put a lot of thought into.
See with this one, it's a big bag!
Very practical, very...
Functional.
There's a black bag inside of it that can actually be removed.
There's also a very nice FUWAMOCO inner lining there!
So you can put in between the black bag and then the plastic.
What kind of plastic clear lining you can put your cam badges in there.
You can put plushies, headlights, figures, anything you want to, you know, make a bit of a statement.
It can be casual, it can be more fun.
There's lots of different ways to be able to show how proud a Ruffian you are.
Depending on the situation, you know, if you want to go on your day-to-day or when you're going to a convention or a special event.
We also have in the set a special voice pack!
It's a system sound voice pack, you know, so you can use it in your daily life!
Have you listened yet, Ruffians?
And it's in English and Japanese too, so I think there's lots of different ways that you can use it.
You can customize it even if you want to.
If physical merch is difficult, there is this as well.
It's digital.
It's digital, you know.
Yeah.
The ringtone is super good.
Yeah!
FUWAMOCO!
Are you having a good life?
Thank you!
But right now pre-orders are open until June 2nd.
Yes!
So we hope that maybe, maybe there could be a discussion with Wallet Club.
And that you'll check it out.
If you so feel like it.
You can check it out.
There's a link in the description over on the official hololive shop.
So please check it out.
In this description.
BAU BAU!
Actually, I lied.
Probably not.
Moco-chan!
I forgot to update it.
BAU BAU!
Let's update it.
You can also check it out on Twitter and the community page, Moco-chan.
BAU BAU.
Try.
We'll get there.
I'm trying.
Yeah.
Oh, this story tab needs to be updated too.
Can I?
FUWAMOCO!
And even more exciting news!
Today at 5.50pm PT on the official hololive English channel.
A bit of a funny time, huh?
A bit of a funny time.
There's going to be a very special 3D program for Enryku-chan, did you know?
Enryku ENigmatic Recollection!
This is such a cool thumbnail.
Nerissa.
Iina-senpai, Caroline-senpai, Korone-senpai, Biboo.
What comes next?
We'll connect all the chains of fate.
There's a lot of mysteries, a lot of questions.
And this was gonna happen in this 3D program.
Apparently there's gonna be... Challenges?
Challenges.
I don't know the way they explained it sounded ominous.
Maybe challenges the challenge the chain of fate.
Who knows?
Well, for more FUWAMOCOs that are like, okay, what is this ENigmatic Recollection thing?
Yes!
Well, for sure N-RECORD!
N-RECORD is a Minecraft roleplay!
Advent that hololive English that we've been doing!
Yeah, hololive English!
It's the start of chapter 2!
Yes!
You know, we had a bunch of fun Chapter 1 all together with everybody.
But just because you didn't catch Chapter 1 doesn't mean that you can't follow along for Chapter 2.
Do not worry.
You know, if you're curious also what did happen in Chapter 1, you can check out there's a bunch of little summary clip videos about the things that happened in Chapter 1.
You know, I would say that that's just to be able to get more hype and record too.
Now recap's right!
But the main event will be starting on Saturday at 7pm PT!
It's just right around the corner now!
We hope that you're looking forward to it as much as us Ruffians!
You'll be there for sure!
BAU BAU!
I can't wait.
Corruption.
Evolution!
BAU BAU!
We're gonna take a look to see who's our Doggie of the Day today!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... It's Luna!
Luna-mama!
Such a sweetie!
Look at that nose!
The cheeks!
This is too cute!
Pupito guys too!
Right!
She's such a pretty color pattern too, right?
FUWAMOCO.
Moc here.
How does Luna bow-bow?
BAU BAU!
You know, we can see from this beautiful photo, she's just such a big sweetie.
I wanna grow up her cheeks.
Right.
You know, her cheeks are big.
Her nose is big.
But, I say deep down, there's also a very, very big heart too.
And you know, I think Luna likes tweets.
Tweets?
Tweets a lot.
But more than that, she loves you.
Not Twitter.
No.
She's not addicted to toilet, she's addicted to you!
So you know, make sure you give her lots and lots of hand pats and belly rubs too.
And that you play with her cheeks too, that's a request from me.
Yeah, requested.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
I love you, do you know that?
It'll be a little bit warmer from spring to summer.
Let's take a look at where you've been going for a walk.
The day I went on a walk, we have... De-den!
Oh, a ski park!
Such a cool ski park.
Yeah, and a city!
And New York City!
New York!
Dun dun dun dun.
I was gonna say, did you break any dimensions at the Skateboard Park?
Yeah.
Yeah?
Ah, Dokonoko is in New York!
But you know, hopefully you had a ton of fun.
That's easily... Yeah.
Heck yeah.
You wanna heck yeah?
HECK YEAH!
BAU BAU!
But it looks cool!
It's very fast!
BAU BAU!
We also received a question from you ruffians on our Question of the Day.
Let's take a look at the question we received.
We have De-den!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
Hello!
I have a question.
Besides playing games, you also have a morning show, FUWAMOCO Morning, a maid cafe, and many other interesting things.
Rock n' Rawr Party!
I don't know Japanese, so I wanted to ask if you could do a Japanese lesson!
This could be very helpful to me and maybe others too!
BAU BAU!
Such a good question!
A long time ago.
Yeah, back when we kinda debuted.
We did do a Japanese classroom together with Advent.
We did our best as teachers.
It was a lot of fun, but our brains also felt like they were about to break.
Yeah.
You know, it's hard when there's like a lot of students, not just Abyss, but you too, Ruffians!
Yeah, and we want to make sure you know that everyone's understanding, having fun.
It's hard with lots of different skill levels, too.
Yeah!
But, you know, there's a lot of fun things about the Japanese language and maybe some areas that aren't as hard as you might think.
Right!
So, if we could do another classroom, maybe teach you a bit.
And make us happy!
I know!
But, uh, I don't know how to do that one.
But it has been discussed.
Yes!
You want us to teach math?
No.
Are you sure about that?
Do you just see the glasses and think, I want to be taught?
That's maybe it, huh?
Is that more of it?
Oh no, please do.
You seem to be contradicting, Ruffians.
Huh?
I would really like to be able to teach you know, the Ruffians more.
Advent more too, so... I don't know who the best teacher is though.
Yeah, I don't know either, but... BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you so much Ruffians for all your submissions!
The hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
You know, sometimes it's kinda nasty to start the day off with a Pero sighting, but
It's very important, so please let us know if you see Pero around.
Even if it's maybe in a little bit of a weird place.
You know, also... If you see a very cute doggy, this is a doggy of a day!
You know, also, if you have any more questions or you go on a really nice walk, please share them with us with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Ah, well, we have another stream coming up very soon!
Very, very soon!
Well... De-den!
We're starting off our FUWAMOCO Mini-Hurricane Matsuri!
Yes!
It's such a fun game to do!
And we'll be starting with night delivery to our game!
It'll be at 9AM JST!
Oh, you know, and we'll also be continuing from there.
I'm on observation duty 1.
There's a bunch of other games, you know.
Maybe some Minecraft fishing in the middle.
Back to it!
But it'll be definitely very silly.
Maybe spooky.
Hopefully not too scary.
And maybe a bit surprising too.
And we'll be playing a bunch of them past midnight too.
Extra spooky, right?
Yeah, we hope you're ready for some mischief!
It's gonna be lots of fun!
Can't wait.
We hope you're ready, Ruffians.
Yeah, it's not howling.
No.
BAU BAU!
And our schedule!
Well, after our mini-horror game matsuri, and FUWAMOCO's just about to start,
I'll be having a lot of fun adventures in Aramako.
But in between there, we're also going to be continuing with Metal Gear Solid 3 on PS2!
We just started having a bunch of fun in the jungle being sneaky.
Very sneaky.
We did not maybe run into a dog the other day in the forest, did we?
Forget about Rufus, okay?
Keep going.
But we'll be having a lot more fun days here, Ruffians.
So we hope you enjoy us.
Enjoy us?
Join us!
For that as well.
To have more fun.
And enjoy time together.
Yeah.
Enjoy.
Us.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Wow, for Ruffians joining us in the Aikai today, new FUWAMOCO word is... It's BAU BAU Shiori Birthday!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much Ruffians for joining us today for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Viper Blade!
BAU BAU!
Kyotaro!
Need.
BAU BAU!
Chibi gear.
Notebooks.
BAU BAU!
Food.
Amanohachi.
BAU BAU!
Alligator.
Dr. Worm.
BAU BAU!
Happy hobby.
Rhyme box.
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!